[Musique]
bienvenue quartier bois connu pour ses
exploitations agricoles c'est ici que
vit et travaille la famille c store
depuis trois générations en nous à les
joindre samuel et nicolas des jeunes
frais agricole sa mais les pings au
label bonjour alors côté nous y ait ici
à et qui salopent café ans les sénateurs
mais lannoy le quai secteur terrain
familial que mon époux et punitifs aux
moyens non partie élevage et donc peut
être qu'après tous niveaux et en partie
mari chi kung koutla et à partir à
bouilly culture
la différence et des parents qui ont
déjà été investis ainsi pour de la vie
pour l'exploitation qui fait que nous
avons repris l'exploitation agricole
depuis l'âge de ses co nos parents nous
amenaient déjà au chant ont commencé
déjà à créer des oignons avec avec ma
mère voilée bové avec mon père
s'était pas quelque chose que je
souhaitais faire puisque sebo j'ai
depuis tout petit on travaille avec les
parents et c'est un métier très
difficile est bon par la suite il m'a
attrapée aujourd'hui je suis retourné
sur les tuyaux avec mon fils tout est
dit pour installer de nouvelles choses
j'ai voulu continuer les études quand
même donc j'ai fait un bts
agronomie en production végétale donc ça
va a repris j'ai eu l'envié d'europol et
de maintenance et dans ça
c'est important de continuer l'élevage
est comme eux on disait il faut
diversifier et nommez moi donc des fois
les productions marie chevrier on ne
rapporte pas suffisamment à peu se
rabattent toujours sur la partie élevage
donc ça représente quand même plus
quand même c'est que pousseur du duché
terre ferme de l'exploitation
et choisit des menaces et un peu dans
les vergers donc là on trouve un peu des
cultures d'antan que mes parents avaient
déjà mais en plus grand à plus grande
échelle comme que votre déco aux
souliers et on a introduit aussi de
nouvelles variétés pour apporter une
dose de fraîcheur comme le citron caviar
la diversification de l'exploitation
fait que on arrive à s'en sortir et le
fossé d'avoir ôté aussi cette friche au
d
dépasser un peu plus en plus exotiques
et puis un peu plus aussi recherché par
le public et que on arrive à se
démarquer parmi tant d'autres
[Musique]
cela fait trois ans que les testeurs ont
repris l'exploitation familiale
après avoir réussi le combat va là
malouda notamment il compte bien
continuer les expérimentations pour
faire vivre leurs activités
[Musique]